this on the daily wire says the uh the
media trade association that vilified
ben shapiro last month for simply
appearing at a recent trade show
apologized on thursday saying its
treatment of the daily wire star wasn't
right
podcast movement the industry's biggest
trade group and host of annual
conferences that bring together top
media companies
said in a statement that it was wrong to
claim that shapiro's presence at its
recent dallas show caused harm
the mayor culpa came after the daily
wire immediate giant cumulus both vowed
to end their support for the
organization so the statement said
as we stated we're continuing to
evaluate our priorities policies uh
rather guiding social media and events
with inclusivity diversity and respect
for all
we have to start by sincerely
apologizing to mr shapiro for our
reaction when he visited a booth that we
that we sold his company that wasn't
right
uh podcast movement began in 2014 with
four podcasters who had an idea to
create a vibrant community that was for
podcasters by podcasters we're still
those people with the same idea and
recognize there's work to do as we grow
they the wire co-founder jeremy boring
who uh at the company's recent backstage
event had blasted podcast movement for
unadulterated bigotry
said uh people rarely admit when they do
wrong particularly on the left where
every cultural indicator reinforces your
error podcast movement did the right
thing with this apology co-founder dan
franks also called me to make clear
their treatment of ben was unacceptable
good on them
jeremy's being very gracious here uh i
am
a slightly less gracious person in
general so
yeah it's an apology it's it's the right
thing to do so you know kind of like
carnegie mello melon responding
to their professor and the horrible
thing she said yeah it's the right thing
to respond to it
but
you know it's to me it's not quite
enough
and especially with podcast movement
yeah they they gave the apology this is
like two weeks later three weeks like
two weeks later
and they're only doing it because they
had no other choice
i mean they tried everything they could
to avoid apologizing
but then once cumulus got on board
and there were more companies you know
having our back on this thing as they
should that podcast movement was like
what choice do they have
if you want to have a podcast conference
a podcast organization and you lose
daily wire and you lose cumulus you
start you start losing
all of the biggest podcasting companies
well then you can't then your company is
gone
so they have no choice and they and they
very begrudgingly finally apologized as
an act of sheer self-preservation
fine
i'm glad they did
but um
i am certainly not at all convinced that
this was uh that this was
[Music]
something that they did because they
really feel that they were wrong and
they're trying to make amends or
whatever
well before you go uh hit the subscribe
button and ring the bell and while
you're at it if you want to go watch or
listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe you can also
catch my show on spotify apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now i demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated